your behalf
she did it and i i was also cheering so
okay so we have a draw
okay okay
so
that means very nice to see
and now we are going to see armageddon
and the players will kick off their
armageddon match
in around 20 minutes we'll keep you
posted on that and uh
that means one thing
richard rapport will be playing white
with the with 10 minutes on the clock
magnus carlsen will have seven minutes
on the clock but draw odds
and uh there will
only be increments after move 41 when it
will be a very glorious one second added
per move
and here we have it the players and
keep repeating the moves quite a few
times
well
this is already gonna be a draw yep
no doubt about it maybe a few more moves
going back and forth you never know but
unexpectedly we are going to have a tie
break after an hour and 20 minutes
already
so
they don't know how to punch each other
i mean i really have this like a year
ago i think it was the i must stay right
yes namaste now it's the fifth pumpkin
and now it's punching
yep